like those kids are amped and they're
really good I get amazed every time I
watch it's like an after-school he's
like a after-school program teacher so
for the arts and stuff up and Abraham
bro he's killing it man he's teaching I
mean I wish I had that time I think you
needed that [ __ ] when you were a kid I
probably did stead of his stuck into a
little classroom I couldn't put you in
that [ __ ] got your Wiggles out and then
you would have smashed it yeah that's
true
you should just show up one day and just
see oh yeah show up to convince his
class I don't even think you know right
now you're actually talking to a [ __ ]
living legend did I really want to hear
that oh that's why he looked at me like
I was a [ __ ] idiot
you want to be like what you want to
hear the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] so on JK
news it was his guy name his name is
Wray anime is his his tag Ryan he's a
part of this dance group called Quest
Crew so I've heard of those guys right
so the American company America's best
tire company so apparently he actually
knew Joe from my junior high back in the
day but never met him but he only knows
Joe because there's a legend about him
what's the legend I kicked out you would
explain the story well I so we both from
the same kind of like religion right and
then so we went to the same private
school and then I find out oh [ __ ] you
went to that school so did I but he went
to high school there and I went to
junior high there and so we never really
met each other so we started naming off
people like oh do you know so-and-so do
you know so-and-so and he was like oh
yeah I know that person and he asks me
hey do you know who Joe mama is and I'm
like I'm Joe mama mama I'm [ __ ] Joe
mom like wait no and I'm like thinking
oh [ __ ] am I being rude like did I
actually know this guy and then he just
doesn't remember me so I was like what
about Joe mama like like who told you
about him and then he was like no it's
just I can't believe I'm finally meeting
you
oh [ __ ] and I'm like what's going on you
know like what's going on what I hear
the funniest [ __ ] that he said after
though he goes how do you know about Joe
mama he goes you're the guy that never
made
what a [ __ ] backhanded compliment no
but there's what he means by that is
that knighted to his high school didn't
make it nice yeah it was like dude [ __ ]
this I'm gonna smoke weed and get kicked
out so what he was yeah it was saying
that after he left Ryan became friends
with the group that he kicked it with
yeah and so when he got kicked out they
would always talk about Joe and they
would call him new Joe Joe Joe he was a
legend because he was such a [ __ ]
badass and he was he was a seventh-day
adventists and so whenever there was a
badass in the school I think he was the
coolest [ __ ] alive so there was
a legend about this guy in high school
so what was the legend what would you do
I don't know I just lived my life you
know sex with all the the hot teachers
no that would be awesome
this will got got smoking weed in the
bathroom yeah I remember you told us a
story last time yeah yeah there was that
Amanda was just a lot of things I would
I was doing and I was just like wild and
out and having fun I didn't know that
they would talk about me but I was just
being myself that's not easy though is
it you know it's kind of cool though is
that he's still connected to a lot of my
old friends and stuff and and then just
through him like I'm starting to see
some old faces and I'm like man that's
that's nostalgic like it's cool
they missed you so much they kept
telling that story to everybody in that
school he was a legend like people talk
about him like he's [ __ ] Van Wilder
dude bro you're [ __ ] your Fonzie your
Fonzie you're [ __ ] fine you didn't
even get to live that glory out which
sucks that's okay I didn't know I just I
was just having fun
do you would've got so much seventh day
of than its [ __ ] yeah you would have
just [ __ ] bang all the girls in high
school you would have been rolling
knee-deep in it there are some cute ones
- they all wanted to get with Joe mama
dude but I don't know about that say
dude that's what you say they want that
Joe mama dick they want that I didn't it
just blew my mind because I was like oh
like I didn't know that cuz I knew some
of the guys and I still kept in contact
and then I'm like oh they miss me that
much that's a great feel I thought the
store was gonna be about how you were
like some breakdancing legend or
something
he was not I don't even know what like
legend - cuz I just kept trying to ask
him like what what what did they talk
about they're like oh man there's so
many stories about you and you were
badass and I'm like what did I do and
then like all these things started
coming into my mind like oh [ __ ] dude
like I remember there was like this big
like Mexican party crew there then they
jumped me in the bathroom and I and we
jumped each other like just for fun at a
seventh day adventists junior high
that's what Victor came out of that's
[ __ ] victory victory ever it's like
Catholic school yes like it's like so I
know it's like a promise we played for
sure you care - rod nice to see oh my
god this is one thing to it so a Shinto
we created like a thief a thief crew yes
guys steal well right next to it was
like a Kmart and just it was just a big
Plaza full of like never it was a
hometown buffet there was Kmart there
was all that and so I don't know like it
was just it was just we got bored right
so we go in there and we just start
going from store to store just stealing
things and then it got bigger and bigger
and we just go into school and sell it
like to our friends what the [ __ ] yeah
and then we used to there used to be a
movie theater it's all gone now it's
kind of like a bunch of restaurants now
but we would just go after school to the
movie theater and just spend the rest of
the day there like hop from one you know
you buy one ticket use another I thought
we were cool
Venice Aladdin that is yeah that is
really cool though because when I was
that age I would never be caught dead
doing any of that stuff oh you're so 13
or 14 I feel like there's so many
stories about kids who were put into
like religious private schools yeah that
rebelled so [ __ ] I learned a lot of
bad [ __ ] from my elementary school
because like my elementary school a lot
of my classmates were like real [ __ ]
hood that's when I got introduced to
like gang culture and all that stuff and
I didn't even know it was gang culture
so like my friends and parents were
Crips
and in life or like they were like
Mexican gangs and like generationally
like their grandpa was like they had a
blue rag and all that stuff that's the
weird thing like when you're a kid you
don't realize the people that you're
hanging out with are a part of anything
bad they're just doing whatever that
they're doing I remember when I was in
[ __ ] high school I was walking around
with some friends and these dudes rolled
up on us and I didn't even know who the
[ __ ] they were but they're like well
suffle what you bang and I looked up and
it was my I'll be like what's up David
hey what's up man and we're just walking
by and then my friends looked at me
they're like how the [ __ ] do you know
those guys did a bunch of [ __ ]
norteños I was like oh I grew up I went
to elementary school with that guy but
you know when you're a kid I just don't
know yeah man yeah but he was a [ __ ]
norteño you would have never known I
would have never known and that's when
that jumps you on right that's
absolutely not dude I was just the
dweeby little goofy kid now they put you
on Dre don't absolutely not man what's
up good I mean what's up blue yeah I
didn't even know what that I thought
they were just like party like just
cruise you know like cuz ya ever since I
was a kid everybody was in a crew like
my cousins were break dance crews or
like tagging crews or whatever right and
in like I guess gangs just existed it
was just a part of the life so I didn't
know that they were hella bad like bad
and get or whatever I didn't know like I
was just like oh I like I like his mom
she always has money and it's like I
didn't know she was a drug dealer I look
back and I'm like oh [ __ ] Judi was doing
yeah
anything cuz my friend was pretty poor
looking but he had three horses right
and in a pony in a [ __ ] he his mom
had like three for a single mom with
three four cars and it was just like I
bought with drug cash yeah yeah it had
to be too cuz she was always home you
know how stupid I was I mentioned this
story on JK news but in Sacramento
there's a huge Hmong community and there
and in my parents store there was like
this Hmong market but I used to I grew
up with a lot of these dudes but they
were a part of a group called there's
two huge Hmong kings I'm not sure if
they're still around they probably are
they're called mo D and H and s box